j'accueille maintenant guy bien globe
guy birenbaum bonsoir êtes éditeur chez
denoël vous avez publié santoni
montebourg halphen le frère de moussaoui
ataman moussaoui que nous avons reçu ici
et pourtant vous avez refusé de publier
le livre de patrick henry
vous l'avez rencontré quand patrick
henry c'était en février 2002 je suis
contacté par une journaliste quelques
liens avec lui et qui me dit patrick
henry veut publié un bouquin est ce que
tu veux le rencontrer
ouais donc moi je suis éditeur comme
vous l'avez dit je fais mon job je
prends ma bagnole et je vais à caen j'ai
rendez vous c'est un matin je me fais un
très bien il pleut à la gare de caen et
je suis dans le parking de la gare de
caen et j'attends j'appelle mon
assistant lui c'est bizarre j'attends
patrick henry c'est le truc est bizarre
dès le départ pour moi arrive quelqu'un
vers moi avec un téléphone portable qui
me dit excusez moi je suis en
communication j'arrive et là j'ai un
premier flash assez étonnant parce que
je ne reconnais pas du tout la personne
qui s'est adressé à moi il ya un truc
qui me passe par la tête je me dis c'est
quand même bizarre donc c'est patrick
henry est gelée par connu du tout
pourquoi il veut qu'on le reconnaisse
oui oui immédiatement
je sais pas pourquoi ça c'est ça qui me
traverse l'esprit donc ici ni sa
conversation et on a convenu il a choisi
un restaurant dans le vieux camp et donc
on part à pied et donc c'est la première
question que je vais lui poser j excusez
moi on se connaît pas je viens vous voir
est ce que c'est vraiment une idée qui
vous semblent pertinentes que de vous
remettre sous les yeux de l'opinion à
lorsque alors qu'il me semble que c'est
même très dangereux
oui peut être agressés donc je lui dis
vous vous rendez bien compte et je sais
un petit peu de quoi je parle puisque
deux auteurs avec qui je travaillais
sont morts françois santoni et avance à
jean michel rossi pas forcément à cause
de leur livre est en tout cas ils sont
morts donc bon j'ai ce truc qui me pèse
dessus et je lui dis donc c'est vraiment
dangereux et il me dit oui oui je sais
bien mais écoutez c'est mon choix c'est
j'ai envie de raconter ce que j'ai vécu
c'est ses 25 ans vous savez pas ce que
c'est que 25 ans de prison jeudi gilles
non bien sûr 50 qhs dans des conditions
absolument épouvantable et donc on
marche donc pendant qu'ils considèrent
qu'il a payé sa dette à la société
donc il dit à ce moment là je peux tout
à fait me remettre dans le regard
non seulement la société mais des
parents c'est rare mais clients les
bertrand qui n'ont jamais rien dit
hamilton jamais fait la moindre
déclaration
c'est la deuxième question quelques
minutes plus tard une fois qu'on est
arrivé au restaurant on s'assoit on
commande on a quand même fait quelques
politesses d'usagé et je lui dis j'ai
une deuxième question pardon d'être très
directe mais on n'a pas beaucoup de
temps
est ce que vous avez pensé à la famille
et il me dit lassé de réponse que je
trouve tout à fait extraordinaire
extraordinaire il me dit c'est
impardonnable
c'est impardonnable mais j'ai payé alors
il voulait faire un livre sur quoi sur
son geste d' assassin disons ou sur la
prison il est sur une problématique de
raconter l'incarcération la souffrance
en prison
est ce que c'est que ces 25 ans et
notamment ses 50 qhs ouais donc je lui
dis tout de suite vous savez ça va pas
marché du tout surtout qui veut plein de
pognon format en parlait mais on parlait
un ça va pas marcher je pense que ça va
pas marcher et je lui dis en a qui vont
pas vous louper c'est la presse pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'aucun de
ceux qui vous ont rencontré à l'époque
nos oublié la façon dont vous les avez
roulé dans la farine jeudi à peu près
comme ça et me dit je sais est
d'ailleurs le premier projet de titres
qu'il a c'est pas le titre qui a été
retenu là c'est plutôt quelque chose sur
la traque et il pense beaucoup à la
façon dont les journalistes l'ont traité
et dont il a lui-même traiter les
journalistes
vie qu'est ce qui intéresse les
visiteurs sur une histoire aussi sordide
où on a vu tout à l'heure les parents
sont restés mais vraiment je n'arrive
pas à trouver le mot mais digne des
régimes et c'est pour ça qu'il veut
intéresser l'éditeur il va le voir il va
le voir je fais mon vous avez raison de
poser cette question parce que je me
pose maintenant la question
je crois que c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça je pense je pense d'abord que
chaque chacun son métier
moi je donne pas de leçons qui n'est pas
donné mais c'est aussi une question est
là pour poser des questions l'aviron des
gens un peu intéressant ce soir là bas
ma vie donc en scène fait une sortie en
même temps et puis jean cot déjà fait
rétorque j'ai mal économique depuis que
c'est le frangin de samy naceri je
rencontre des gens vachement intéressant
en revanche pas de questions moi j'ai la
chance d'en écrire un bouquin est un
éditeur que moi
j'ai pas tué patrick enfin je veux pas
être intéressant c'est l'asie alors oui
du en continu dans dedans je pense que
mon travail c'est de rencontrer les gens
attention je vais vous faire une petite
révélation moi j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone il ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines d'un intermédiaire est dans le
milieu de l'édition c'est comme dans la
presse il ya des espèces d'un formateur
ou d'intermédiaires qui tourne comme ça
et qui donne des infos et quelqu'un me
dit tiens j'ai une proposition à te
faire h 10 ha bon un vieux qui est sorti
de prison il ya pas longtemps ça
t'intéresse
non si je dis tu te fous de moi
maintenant il dit c'est sérieux bagis je
pense que tu te fous de moi donc pour
vous répondre maurice papon
j'y vais pas alors c'est très bizarre
parce que bon il veut de l'argent et
beaucoup d'argent il vous dit loana a eu
un million pas c'est pas moi qui dis ça
comme ça moi c'est beaucoup plus c'est
différent c'est à dire je reviens sur la
question du départ jeudi c'est dangereux
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus et il me
dit mais moi mon objectif c'est d'avoir
une maison au bout d'un jardin avec un
système de vidéosurveillance et c'est là
où je lui ai dit pardonnez moi je vous
répète ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure
ne vous faites pas connaître le risque
pour vous c'est qu'on vous reconnaisse
ça sert à rien d'avoir une maison avec
une vidéo surveillance restez comme vous
êtes et vous en avez le droit et donc
vous finalement vous refuser de le
publier
pourquoi à cause de la famille à cause
de cette obsession d'être connu ce que
dit très justement son avocat c'est que
patrick henry n'est plus patrick henry
de toute façon il est sous dimensionné
par rapport à ce qui lui est arrivé et
c'est vrai quand on le rencontre il est
largué c'est un type seul c'est pas
normal d'une certaine manière que je
sois en tête à tête avec ce type dans un
restaurant à quand je me le dis parce
que je voulais dire c'est qu'en fait il
est un peu dépassée dans le symbole
qu'il est devenu il ya un symbole à la
fois de la lutte contre la peine de mort
est symbole à la fois de la confiance
qu'on peut avoir en l'air à l'insertion
oui alors en tous les cas merci de votre
témoignage me berenboom ya une autre
polémique qui agite en ce moment les
médias et la france c'est l'interdiction
qui pèsent sur rose bonbon le livre de
nicholas johnson golinger gallimard sera
peut être interdit
lundi alors on a beaucoup parlé de son
livre lui a refusé de s'exprimer sauf
pour une émission qui s'appelle rive
droite rive gauche et qui est diffusée
tous les soirs à 19h10 sur paris
première